- First of all most sex toy
things are just kitchen items,
just let's get that straight.
(upbeat music)
- What else can this be really?
- There's a disco situation here.
- Like it's got two little disco balls
and they turn.
- Does it vibrate or anything? No.
- It kind of looks like
a dolphin with balls.
- I think I want to say sex toy.
(buzzes)
(laughs)
- Dog toy.
This is totally a dog toy.
- There's something inside of the ball
that's jiggling around as well.
- Like if I'm stressed out
I feel like I could just
shake this at my desk.
- I'm gonna say it's not a sex toy
but I'm not sure what this is.
(dings)
- I know what this is.
It's for pizza.
- Is this what you use to make ravioli?
- It's a lot of pain I feel like.
- This is like making pasta, maybe?
Like a pasta cutter.
- I'd be really fucking
shocked if this was used
as a sex toy.
(dings)
- So we've got a very
long metallic object.
- Good sturdy implement.
- The bottom has like a texture to it.
- You get that stab a
stick and you just go
you just go at it.
- I feel like you could
use this to muddle herbs
for drinks right?
(buzzes)
- It kind of feels like a balloon.
- It's rubbery.
- No, it's not a bracelet.
It's too small.
- You could probably
use this as a hair tie.
- These are very tricky.
- To conceal some chips.
I don't know.
- This is definitely a sex toy.
(dings)
This is glass which means
this is definitely not
for a dog.
- I don't know, I kind
of think rock candy.
- Covered in little, nibbly, nubbly's.
- I personally would use
this as a paperweight.
- It feels like a massage,
like a pressure point thing.
- I still don't think this is a sex toy.
(dings)
- Super easy to grip.
- Yeah it's not flimsy,
it's not gonna break.
- This is really, really, really spikey.
- This looks like what you
would use to hold corn.
- This is definitely not a sex toy.
(buzzes)
- What is this?
What is this?
- Not a sexy green color.
- This feels like part of a vacuum.
- This looks like it fell
of of something else.
- Does this go on a hose?
- I, not a sex toy.
(buzzes)
- Oh it's heavier than
I thought it would be.
- I don't, I can't tell if this is like a
a metal band.
- I would think you would you
know, play catch with this
maybe?
- It's probably a sex toy.
(dings)
- Rub away.
- It's metal.
It's pretty hard.
- I don't know what this is.
It looks like a bar of soap.
- I feel like this one
is like a trick object.
- I feel like this is a soap holder.
- I don't think this is a sex toy.
(buzzes)
- For one thing, it looks
like a luxury product.
- Does the top come up?
It's vibrating.
- What's that.
Yeah I know what that is.
- Well this can really only be one thing.
- Oh yup this is a sex toy.
(buzzes)
- I feel a little grandma-ish right now,
'cause I missed a lot of those.
- I'm just really upset.
I don't know how to feel.
- We're creative people, both
in and out of the bedroom.
- Also I thought everything was a dildo
which is like, of course I would.
(upbeat music)
(whooshes and squeaks)